turn lights on let's get started what's
up GQ y'all been asking
I brought the jury I brought the rocks
out this is what I said on the rocks
yes sir Wow my first chain though from
Bad and boozy wade himself was this
right here
the Rancho emoji it was a 50 just for my
boy Elliott he'd do a lot of my cousin
pieces and I got dropped off on the bed
so it's rain drop drop top ten after
this piece I got the offset and you know
I always be talking about me dripping so
I got the letters actually dripping like
it's drips coming from the bottom of the
letters along right here this is 60 just
a piece no Chang this right here is one
of my favorites I got this after tile
sets high there's a two-song rose and
white cross they're white diamonds
around and each day they care and then
this is two and a half carat where's the
pink star so I paid 220 just for this
piece right here
I just got this nice long before icebox
just right here I'm just like 25,000 I
want to ice it all the way out I want so
no medal this right here this solid
foundation you know this management with
the whole team and you see I said watch
Madras for pink and coach they gave us
all these shine cuz we got family then
this one right here this is a big
diamond she's a big like big big big big
big big big big big stars
yeah I'm saying bro mass stars is a
carrot and a half a piece this chain by
itself is 150 it's just this little shy
right here this is my wife
hi she got the lot of money other nice
ones we're like a little longer because
she's got a big old car to beat a be
stuffed up so much I think she paid 150
because she got a diamond chain to go
with it which is a carat yeah I might
throw her Smyth on last why we all want
yeah I'm saying no cabin in my game I'd
be holding up sticker sometimes you just
fire her chain it costs a hundred bands
and the bottom of her purse was crumbs
on it this is the vendors to bender
emoji that was our first song that was
like they got us notice from Gucci I
said told us and like and that Len was
the first song so it was like the home
base and it's a home so I put five
thirty where we were standing on an off
side because that's what we came from
the basement mama crib
then you open though it's this the man
who welcomes you to the trap
and that's a guy with he's holding a
chocolate you got a stove in there a
rose ghost over rose gold pie you got a
money bag this was 250 a quarter it's
heavy too
he's more than the kilo this Cuban that
it's all man or whatever we've thought
about this it's never been done
it's like a new style of Cuba this
custom ironing over the collar but don't
bite the jerk
this is yellow feeding from Elliot it's
two rows so the DOM is a bit bigger and
it's prong-set so they kind of poke out
the Diamonds poke out little more on
this one he was the first one to do the
prong set it's like a new way of doing
it it's smaller than it it's still 60
because the stone was big I got this
right here this is a baguette achieve a
lot of rappers right now I was right
about the guess I was the first one with
these baguettes I had this last year and
I had like a watch to go with it it was
a schedule I don't got in the mortar
just right here I got really he ain't do
me too bad it's like 45 it's just a
regular Cuba I stopped it's white this
right here is called Franco it's like
back in the day was like three little
Cubans against a longer one it's like
what the 80s we're back in the day but
it was a skinny channel but I may have
put them boogers on that thing and poked
around but earlier I said and that's an
interesting range it shows that this
ring right here that's the big dollar
side got 50 partners diamonds in the
middle all white all the way butts down
just one costing 40,000 boxes this is a
Cuba there's a queue area look pinkie
ring I'm saying you're feeling good you
got a little pink y'all yeah this one it
was like a looks 20 just right here
there's a star cuz I'm gonna start a
shooting star with the baguettes in the
inside and the front of it a little
different this is like 30 it's one of my
favorites right here this is a pinkie
ring right here but he got a solid we
get in the middle I've got a carrot and
a half this is 60 just for this round
this my hair this will good lying down
who likes on the top not too special my
boy Metro and my brother - it's a
lightning bolt inside of a clock because
his album was called perfect timing
chopped up I left you know saying he
goes so hard for his artist we have a
residency at Dresden so I get on the
stage to perform he like yo bro thank
you both for being a part of NAB's I
haven't believed in my little bro and he
gave me this ring so it's like I guess
it's just like a championship ring it's
also another pinkie ring that's it on a
pinkie and I got these I just got these
the ice box career bun style diamonds on
the side on the front this is like
18,000 like one of my favorite shows I'm
really gonna keep them all for the rest
of the video you late - are I haven't
even really took mop these prescription
glasses now you drip glasses yes sir can
you swap these out - just know my stilo
continuity actually know about that
continuity unlike I'm through with the
eyes I'm really stuck on the watches I
mean my wife's collection up this is a
Ling Hwa's addition it's a Richard Mille
they got two strikes because of leave
Mars is a race
it's like 170 it go up in time nothing
tomorrow's edition but it's diamond ah
but it's factory so just like too funny
when you ready to have a bus style you
should get like factory it comes ahead
because the value in your money stays
safe like a house it's a beautiful thing
you learn in the watches how they move
and just take your time don't wanna come
to zero just take your time perhaps of
rose gold paddock like 129 south and
then we want to get grown I pull out the
Rose go playing them
that's the Hodge of bass its plays out
you know you went to business media I
would have to Vegas I get stopped out of
time if I'm like the big ball players I
like but you know about these watches
from man watch
so I walked the Lully on Rodale on like
two three years ago and they like you
know we have a painter here to pay
anything so I just say him his picture
and then he came back like two days
later like look I'm like dad so crazy
it looked exactly like the picture my
wife's ran that's the most that's the
best one he knows marriage and you know
making it official like under the air
five hundred bands to on the pear-shaped
diamond big boy with the pink stones
that pink diamonds around it going
around and shrimp I've seen a lot of
copycats to since we got that ring you
know Saturday the same yeah I got one
said I don't get too many says because
sometimes I poke you make a tea program
and I got our beautiful smile I'm sad so
I don't wanna you know interrupt that
and then my wife don't really like it
like that she's like somehow fish you
could wear it or something off is you
know leave it alone I got a little one
Rosa Lopez shot it was Johnny dad but on
my birthday I got a super get but
Gabriel I'll beget well I got so much I
got more in this brothers just some of
them
including everything how much $3 your
honor I love Jerry man she's a great
feeling that my Giri all just like
confident starting to just something
work for tourists though it's short like
my work and I'm saying is this is this
what I like to get from it that first it
was two of these three of these and one
I won't watch em say I'm in my head just
one Chang this one little diamonds ham
now I got this I'm just moving on up